Jake: 好可惜啊
Jake: So unfortunate
Jake: 这要怎么抓
Jake: How do you grab this?
Jake: 这好抓吗
Jake: Is this easy to grab?
Tasha: 不好抓吧
Tasha: Not easy to grab, right?
Tasha: 你觉得好抓吗
Tasha: Do you think it's easy?
Jake: 抓一个我不知道
Jake: Grabbing one, I don't know
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Alice: 爪子超松的
Alice: The claw is super loose
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah
Jake: 会抓吗
Jake: Can it grab?
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah
Jake: 这个这这是不是很难抓呀
Jake: Is this really hard to grab?
Tasha: 这种很难抓啊
Tasha: This kind is really hard to grab
Jake: 这个好大好大
Jake: This is so big, so big
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 他爪子会松
Lucia: The claw will loosen
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah
Alice: 给你一点甜头
Alice: It gives you a little advantage
Alice: 让你觉得离他近在咫尺
Alice: Makes you feel like you're so close
Jake: 对开心一会
Jake: Yeah, happy for a moment
Jake: 开心个5秒
Jake: Happy for 5 seconds
Lucia: 那边还有那个开车和射击的游戏
Lucia: There's also that driving and shooting game over there.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 我刚去玩了一局射击回来
Lucia: I just played a round of the shooting game.
Jake: 哈哈看看修硕打怎么样了
Jake: Haha, let's see how Shure is doing.
Jake: 过弯了吗哥
Jake: Did you make the turn, bro?
Shure:  过了过了
Shure: Made it, made it.
Jake: 过了过了
Jake: Made it, made it.
Shure:  换一个换一个吧
Shure: Let's switch, let's switch.
Jake: 可以可以行行
Jake: Sure, sure, that's fine.
Jake:你要玩吗
Jake: Do you want to play?
Tasha: 我没有带手套哎
Tasha: I didn't bring gloves.
Shure:  最后再来4个
Shure: Let's do four more rounds.
Shure:  我再找找
Shure: I'll look for more.
Tasha: 你看他们都要戴手套玩
Tasha: Look, they're all wearing gloves to play.
Jake: 摩手是吧
Jake: To warm their hands, right?
Jake: 这是我们现在唯一的成果对吧
Jake: This is our only result so far, right?
Jake: 可以还有8个
Jake: Okay, there are still eight left.
Alice: 三眼仔
Alice: The three-eyed guy.
Katrina:  玩个那个去
Katrina: Let's play that one.
Katrina:  去不去玩那种打打打杀杀的
Katrina: Do you want to play the fighting game?
Jake: 你们要打这个
Jake: You guys want to play this?
Katrina:  不够了不够啊 10个币
Katrina: Not enough, not enough, we need 10 tokens.
Jake: 不够了哦不够
Jake: Not enough? Oh, not enough.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake: 再抓一个
Jake: Let's grab one more.
Tasha: 还有币吗
Tasha: Do we still have tokens?
Jake: 这有几个币啊
Jake: How many tokens do we have?
Tasha: 这要3个币
Tasha: This needs 3 tokens.
Jake: 还剩4个币
Jake: We have 4 tokens left.
Tasha: 嘿嘿嘿
Tasha: Hehe.
Jake: 再来两局
Jake: Let's do two more rounds.
Tasha: 呃是不是一边要投三个
Tasha: Uh, do we need to put three on each side?
Tasha: 还是一共三个
Tasha: Or just three in total?
Jake: 一共三个吧
Jake: Just three in total, I think.
Jake: 打一架
Jake: Let's have a fight.
Tasha: 先来第一架
Tasha: First round.
Tasha: 第二架
Tasha: Second round.
Tasha: 输的一个人背一个人在玩第二场
Tasha: The loser carries the winner for the second round.
Jake: 这
Jake: This...
Tasha: 快点
Tasha: Hurry up.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yay
Jake: 啊怎么这么多
Jake: Ah, why are there so many?
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha
Jake: 对不起对不起对不起对不起
Jake: Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry
Jake: 这什么呀这是
Jake: What is this?
Jake: 啊哈哈啊啊啊哈哈
Jake: Ahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈什么
Tasha: Haha, what?
Jake: 啊哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ahahaha
Tasha: 开心吗啊
Tasha: Are you happy now?
Tasha:  这下你满意了吗
Tasha: Are you satisfied now?
Alice: 走吧啊
Alice: Let's go, huh?
Tasha: 这下你满意了
Tasha: Now are you satisfied?
Jake:这这
Jake: This, this
Jake: 哈哈是
Jake: Haha, yes
Alice: 今天出行是不是对手势不太利啊
Alice: Is today's outing not good for gestures?
Tasha: 哈哈拿给秀儿看一下啊
Tasha: Haha, show it to Shure
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Tasha: 啊啊啊哈
Tasha: Ahaha
Jake: 啊啊啊哈
Jake: Ahaha
Jake: 啊哈
Jake: Aha
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah
Jake: 哈哈哈你你这个不亮了
Jake: Hahaha, it's not lighting up
Jake: 你这你这没电了吗
Jake: Is it out of power?
Tasha: 没电了吗
Tasha: Is it out of power?
Tasha: 他的心可能碎了啊
Tasha: Maybe his heart is broken
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah
Shure:  还有还有多少个
Shure: How many are left?
Jake: 快没了
Jake: Almost gone
Shure:  还有五五个
Shure: There are five left
Shure:  标一次有10个吗
Shure: Marking one has ten?
Shure:  有有人跟我标一下吗
Shure: Can someone mark this for me?
Jake: 飙什么呀
Jake: Mark what?
Shure:  标一下这个
Shure: Mark this
Jake: 这个是多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Shure:  五个一次
Shure: Five at a time
Jake: 这么多啊
Jake: That's a lot
Jake: 感觉凑这边还有两个
Jake: Feels like there are two more here
Jake: 谁要跟他标
Jake: Who wants to mark with him?
Shure:  这只有5个
Shure: There are only five
Shure:  不够了
Shure: Not enough.
Jake: 五个现在总共凑不出来了
Jake: We can't come up with five now.
Tasha: 水呢
Tasha: Where's the water?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Tasha: 水呢
Tasha: Where's the water?
Jake: 好好啊
Jake: Okay, okay.
其他人：她怎么了
Others: What's up with her?
Jake: 他找水去
Jake: She's looking for water.
Shure:  哦那边3币
Shure: Oh, three coins over there.
Shure:  来来那个来那个
Shure: Come on, that one, that one.
Shure:  那个给我飙一下
Shure: Give me a boost with that one.
Jake: 哦不够了
Jake: Oh, it's not enough.
Jake: 这个可以吧
Jake: Is this okay?
Jake: 围观大围观
Jake: Everyone, gather around, gather around.
Jake: 一群赛博人进达赛博区域
Jake: A group of cyber people entering the cyber zone.
Jake: 会开车吗
Jake: Can you drive?
Katrina:  会开哈哈
Katrina: Yes, I can, haha.
Jake: 怎么还有怎么在拍我啊
Jake: Why are you still filming me?
Jake: 啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Katrina:  请把获取的二维码放来
Katrina: Please display the QR code you obtained.
Shure:  没事不用管
Shure: It's okay, don't worry about it.
Jake: 为什么都在拍我呢
Jake: Why is everyone filming me?
Jake: 呵呵干嘛
Jake: Haha, what's up?
Jake: 这个地方
Jake: This place...
Katrina:  不知道啊
Katrina: No idea.
Katrina:  哪个是刹车和哪个
Katrina: Which one is the brake and which one...
Jake: 这这相机是
Jake: This camera is...
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake: 你得到这注册一下还是这个意思是吧
Jake: Do you need to register here, or is that what you mean?
Shure:  对但是可以不注册
Shure: Yes, but you don't have to register.
Jake: 是上车之前拍个照
Jake: So, you take a picture before getting in the car.
Jake: 然后再上车
Jake: Then get in the car.
Jake: 考驾照啊
Jake: Taking a driving test?
Katrina:  这为啥一直要那个
Katrina: Why do we keep needing that?
Shure:  你直接开始跳过对
Shure: Just start, skip it.
Jake: 就开始开始呗开始
Jake: Just start, start then, start.
Katrina:  向上拉动扣子
Katrina: Pull the lever up.
Shure:  当然是开我的AE86了
Shure: Of course, I'm driving my AE86.
Jake: 找不到了
Jake: Can't find it.
Tasha: 嗯不过没关系
Tasha: Hmm, but it's okay.
Tasha: 一瓶水而已
Tasha: It's just a bottle of water.
Jake: 对反正好说
Jake: Yeah, anyway, it's no big deal.
Shure:  然后选那个店内对战
Shure: Then select the in-store battle.
Katrina:  自动挡哈哈
Katrina: Automatic mode, haha.
Shure:  啊选那个店内对战
Shure: Ah, select the in-store battle.
Katrina:  哪啊
Katrina: Where?
Shure:  往往往右往右往右对对
Shure: Go, go, go right, go right, go right, yes, yes.
Shure:  然后开始
Shure: Then start.
Shure:  拉车队
Shure: Form a team.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha: 没有币了
Tasha: We're out of coins.
Jake: 没有币了
Jake: We're out of coins.
Jake: 币用光了吗
Jake: Are the coins used up?
Jake: 还是还有
Jake: Or do we have more?
Jake: 还有最后一个
Jake: We have one last one.
Shure:  还有最后一个
Shure: We have one last one.
Katrina:  还有一个
Katrina: We have one more.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 还有一个币
Jake: We have one coin left.
Jake: 能干嘛
Jake: What can we do with it?
Jake: 这个啊这这一个币
Jake: This one, this, this one coin.
Jake: 我靠呵呵呵
Jake: Oh my god, haha.
Alice: 真是一个币卧槽
Alice: It's really just one coin, damn.
Jake: 我靠真的
Jake: Oh my god, seriously.
Jake: 好看你表演吧
Jake: Okay, let's see you perform.
Jake: 路亚那边有几个币他人呢
Jake: How many coins does Luya have over there? Where is he?
Jake: 找找去啊先
Jake: Let's go find him first.
Jake: 那你你坐着坐着就放一会
Jake: Then you, you sit here and wait a bit.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 哪去了
Jake: Where did he go?
Jake: 找不到一点
Jake: Can't find him at all.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yeah!
Lucia: 这个也好长时间
Lucia: This has been taking a long time.
Lucia: 我在这玩了好久了
Lucia: I've been playing here for a long time.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Impressive.
Jake: 还还有币吗
Jake: Do we still have any coins left?
Lucia: 好像还有几个
Lucia: It seems like there are a few left.
Jake: 还有还有几个呀
Jake: How many do we have left?
Lucia: 还有123 789
Lucia: We have 1, 2, 3... 7, 8, 9.
Jake: 好好多币
Jake: Wow, a lot of coins.
Jake: 可以我剩下
Jake: Alright, I have one left.
Jake: 剩下都只剩一个币了
Jake: I only have one coin left.
Jake: 只有你现在看你表演
Jake: All you can do now is watch your performance.
Lucia: 因为我玩的时间都很长啊
Lucia: Because I play for a long time.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Lucia: 就我一局就可以玩三五分钟那种
Lucia: I can play a round for three to five minutes.
Jake: OK像这个3币就下去了
Jake: OK, like this, 3 coins are gone.
Lucia: 对我我抓了
Lucia: Yeah, I grabbed it.
Jake: 1秒3币就对
Jake: 3 coins in one second, right?
Lucia: 我抓了两次
Lucia: I grabbed it twice.
Lucia: 我决定不抓了
Lucia: I decided not to grab anymore.
Lucia: 太费币了
Lucia: It's too costly.
Jake: OK对对对对
Jake: OK, right, right, right.
Lucia: 你们还要玩点啥吗
Lucia: Do you guys want to play anything else?
Jake: 还还得学经济学
Jake: Still need to learn economics.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 那当然了
Lucia: Of course.
Jake: 这些都是浮云
Jake: All these are just fleeting clouds.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Lucia: 对对这种这种就是成本太高了
Lucia: 收获太低
Lucia: And the returns are too low.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Lucia: 你要玩点啥吗
Lucia: Do you wanna play something?
Lucia: 还有9个
Lucia: We still have 9.
Lucia: 咱三个人可以一人玩一局
Lucia: The three of us can each play a round.
Jake: 呵呵确实
Jake: Haha, for sure.
Jake: 在晃悠晃悠
Jake: Just wandering around.
Jake: 他们在开车
Jake: They're driving.
Lucia: 哎我也去开
Lucia: Oh, I'll go drive too.
Lucia: 你们要开吗
Lucia: Do you guys wanna drive?
Jake: 可以开
Jake: Sure, we can drive.
Jake: 你这有9个币
Jake: You have 9 coins here.
Jake: 那能凑10 哎
Jake: Can we make it 10?
Jake: 能凑10个吗
Jake: Can we get to 10?
Lucia: 不开我就去玩跳舞机了
Lucia: If not, I'll just go play the dance machine.
Shure:  win
Shure: Win.
Katrina:  win
Katrina: Win.
Lucia: 还有谁要玩的吗
Lucia: Anyone else wanna play?
Lucia: 在我只能玩一个人
Lucia: Otherwise, I'll just play solo.
Shure:  还有几个币的
Katrina:  我这还有
Katrina: I still have more.
Katrina:  还可以再再开个车
Katrina: I can still drive another round.
Shure:  因为他赢了
Shure: Because he won.
Shure:  他是不需要再投币子的
Shure: He doesn't need to insert coins again.
Shure:  所以如果想玩的话可以再来一次
Shure: So if you want to play, you can go again.
Shure:  杨老板要试试吗
Shure: Jake, do you want to try?
Jake: 再来一局
Jake: Another round.
Lucia: 那我跟你再来一局哈哈哈
Lucia: Then I'll have another round with you, haha.
Katrina:  那你俩玩
Katrina: Then you two play.
Jake: 行
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 所以啥意思
Lucia: So what does that mean?
Lucia: 是你那边不用投是吧
Lucia: You don't need to insert coins, right?
Jake: 这你还可以续一局是吧
Jake: So you can continue another round, right?
Shure:  对我可以续一局
Shure: Yes, I can continue another round.
Jake: 哦你无论如何都有一局
Jake: Oh, you always have one more round.
Jake: 你那个币是怎么花的呀
Jake: How did you spend your coins?
Jake: 还没花了
Jake: Haven't spent them yet.
Jake: 可以捐了一毛
Jake: You can donate a dime.
Lucia: 然后我按开始吗
Lucia: Then do I press start?
Shure:  对你按开始
Shure: Yes, you press start.
Jake: 现在还剩几个呀不剩了
Jake: How many are left now? None left.
Shure:  正好对
Shure: Exactly right.
Shure:  正好不胜
Shure: Exactly none left.
Jake: 确实不剩了应该
Jake: Indeed, none left, I think.
Shure:  你们你们
Shure: You guys, you guys.
Shure:  谁要再来一局
Shure: Who wants another round?
Shure:  还有人要来一局吗
Shure: Anyone else wants another round?
Jake: 这个这个意思是
Jake: This, this means...
Jake: 这个意思是
Jake: This means...
Jake: 我再投一个币就可以算了吧
Jake: I can just insert one more coin, right?
Jake: 好像不是哦
Jake: Seems like not.
Jake: 是啊那我就开始玩了
Jake: Yeah, then I'll start playing.
Tasha: 不能一起玩吗
Tasha: Can't we play together?
Jake: 这啥意思啊
Jake: What does that mean?
Jake: 可以你你你先扔吧
Jake: Okay, you go first then.
Tasha: 我不会你扔过吗
Tasha: I don't know how. Have you thrown it before?
Jake: 我靠哦好吧
Jake: Damn, okay.
Jake: 他就是给你一个模拟
Jake: It's just a simulation for you.
Jake: 哦我扔掉了两个球
Jake: Oh, I threw away two balls.
Tasha: 哦我扔掉了两个球
Tasha: Oh, I threw away two balls.
Jake: 那你可能你现在要把
Jake: So, you might need to...
Jake: 你还有一轮
Jake: You have one more round
Jake: 你要把剩下的给干掉
Jake: You need to finish off the remaining ones
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Jake: 保龄球就是这样
Jake: That's how bowling works
Jake: 就是每人有两个机会
Jake: Everyone has two chances
Jake: 然后你争取这两轮就把他给全部干掉
Jake: So, you try to knock them all down in those two rounds
Tasha: 为什么我老是这样子
Tasha: Why do I always do like this?
Jake: 我来展示一下
Jake: Let me show you
Tasha: 好您您来
Tasha: Sure, you go ahead
Jake: 但是我我可能哎他哦
Jake: But I, I might, uh, oh
Jake: 他两边如果碰到应该就下去了
Jake: If it hits both sides, it should go down
Jake:它还是
Jake: It still...
Alice: 买菜了
Alice: Bought groceries
Tasha: 有什么了不起的哈哈哈
Tasha: What's the big deal? Hahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈请
Jake: Hahaha, please
Jake: 火鸡大奖啊
Jake: Turkey prize, huh?
Jake: 这个还可以扔
Jake: You can still throw this
Jake: 啥意思啊
Jake: What does that mean?
Jake: 能干嘛呀
Jake: What can it do?
Tasha: 彩票哦我猜的
Tasha: Lottery ticket, I guess
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Jake: 没有请
Jake: No, please
Tasha: 怎么怎么来
Tasha: How do you do it?
Jake: 就唉我靠
Jake: Just, oh man
Jake: 怎么玩就这样嘛
Jake: How to play, just like this
Jake: 就这样然后肩得平肩得平
Jake: Like this, keep your shoulders level, shoulders level
Tasha: 肩得平啊
Tasha: Shoulders level, huh?
Jake: 对不过
Jake: Yes, but...
Jake: 哎呀我去啊
Jake: Oh my gosh
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay
Jake: 你还有一次
Jake: You still have one more
Jake: 好点好点
Jake: Better, better
Jake: 你来你来你来
Jake: You go, you go, you go
Jake: 哦这个这个好
Jake: Oh, this, this is good
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
Jake: 来你的伙计大奖
Jake: Come, your turkey prize
Jake: 这一块钱花的值
Jake: That one dollar was well spent
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah hahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈问题不大
Jake: Hahaha, no problem.
Jake: 因为他右边也很多哈哈
Jake: Because there are a lot on his right side too, haha.
Jake: 我觉得你真到哪都没什么关系啊
Jake: I think it doesn't really matter where you go.
Jake: 你真到哪都没什么关系
Jake: It really doesn't matter where you go.
Tasha: 就比你少了一拼
Tasha: Just a bit less than you.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Tasha: 这一块钱花的值
Tasha: This one dollar was well spent.
Jake: 是还有
Jake: Yes, there's more.
Jake: 这太值了吧我靠
Jake: This is so worth it, gosh.
Jake: 还还有那种花火
Jake: And there are those fireworks too.
Jake: 哎我靠
Jake: Oh gosh.
Tasha: 好滑
Tasha: So slippery.
Jake: 这已经这已经下去了
Jake: It's already gone down.
Tasha: 两瓶
Tasha: Two bottles.
Jake: 哈哈哈再来再来
Jake: Hahaha, more, more.
Jake: 不过这个有点离谱
Jake: But this is a bit ridiculous.
Jake: 就是这个
Jake: Like this one.
Jake: 因为因为他和现实不一样
Jake: Because it's different from reality.
Jake: 所以我可以直接砸过去
Jake: So I can just throw it over.
Jake: 就像这样
Jake: Just like this.
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 就很离谱
Jake: It's so ridiculous.
Tasha: 补中
Tasha: Hit the target.
Jake: 补中
Jake: Hit the target.
Tasha: 火机大奖
Tasha: Lighter grand prize.
Jake: 没有再来
Jake: No, one more time.
Tasha: 必须要一把全部击中才能火急大将吗
Tasha: Do you have to hit them all at once to get the grand prize?
Jake: 好像是对对对
Jake: Seems like it, yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哦总分引出来了呀
Tasha: Oh, the total score is out.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: OK OK
Tasha: OK, OK.
Jake: OK欢迎
Jake: OK, welcome.
Tasha: 值
Tasha: Worth it.
Jake: 值
Jake: Worth it.
Jake: 太值了这一块钱我再来收
Jake: So worth it, I'll collect this one dollar again.
Jake: 呃但是一个币都没有了
Jake: Uh, but there's no coin left.
Tasha: 那还有一个币可以玩啊
Tasha: There's still one coin left to play.
Jake: 哈哈那边还有一个币啊
Jake: Haha, there's still one coin over there.
Tasha: 射蓝我也挺喜欢玩的
Jake: 好你还有
Jake: 一次还还可以吗
Lucia: 还可以吗
Lucia: 我我我不知道
Jake: 是吧是啊
Lucia: 是我就随便按一下
Jake: 决决定吧
Shure:  对这没没有用了
Shure:  因为他得续费的
Jake: 哎啊没了
Jake: 收获满满
Shure:  就他抓到了是吗
Jake: 对还好还好有个东西证明我们来过
Jake: 不然这一段可能就撵不上
Shure: 可以做一下装饰组
Jake: 对对对然后问这哪来的对
Jake: 还有啊
Jake: There's more?
Lucia: 我刚拿了大概15个的样子
Lucia: I just took about 15.
Lucia: 居然还有仨
Lucia: And there are still three more.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake: 还有还有三个
Jake: There's still three more.
Lucia: 可能因为我一直都在玩那些游戏
Lucia: Maybe because I've been playing those games.
Lucia: 花的时间很久
Lucia: Spent a lot of time.
Lucia: 所以他现在还有三个
Lucia: So, now there are still three left.
Shure:  我们我们用钱生钱
Shure: We, we make money with money.
Jake: 有
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 这能推下来吗
Lucia: Can this be pushed down?
Jake: 呃那边还有一个保龄球一块钱
Jake: Uh, there's a bowling game for one dollar over there.
Jake: 玩了很久
Jake: Played for a long time.
Jake: 因为前面有个人投了两个币
Jake: Because someone put in two coins earlier.
Jake: 还剩一个就可以玩
Jake: Just one more coin and you can play.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: 然后我们在钱生钱这这这这这这
Jake: Then we can make money with money, this, this, this.
Jake: 我们就可以收位一下
Jake: We can take a seat.
Jake: 看有没有3-2-3的对3-4的哈哈哈
Jake: See if there's a 3-2-3 against a 3-4, hahaha.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 我看看他他们说说哪个
Lucia: Let me see what they're talking about.
Jake: 213
Jake: 213.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Shure:  还去啊哈哈哈
Shure: Going again, hahaha
Jake: 买买买买个买个2/3 对
Jake: Buy, buy, buy, let's buy 2/3, right.
Shure:  这个吗这只只需要投一个就可以
Shure: For this one, you only need to cast one vote.
Jake: 2-32-3呢李凯有个神仙有个菩萨
Jake: For 2-32-3, Li Kai has a deity, a Bodhisattva.
Shure:  因为有有一个人投了两个
Shure: Because someone cast two votes.
Jake: 有个菩萨之前
Jake: There was a Bodhisattva before.
Tasha: 这个刚刚是也投了俩
Tasha: This one just cast two votes as well.
Jake: 对这个也是2/3
Jake: Yes, this one is also 2/3.
Jake: 这也是2/3
Jake: This one is also 2/3.
Lucia: 神奇
Lucia: Amazing.
Lucia: 谁先来
Lucia: Who's first?
Jake: 来了
Jake: Here we go.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Lucia: 哇居然是现实和屏幕结合
Lucia: Wow, reality and screen combined.
Jake: 哈哈哈是耶
Jake: Hahaha, yeah.
Lucia: 哇厉害
Lucia: Wow, impressive.
Shure:  strike全垒打懂吗
Shure: Strike, home run, you know?
Jake: 来你还有一个
Jake: Come on, you have one more.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Shure:  练过的练过
Shure: Practiced, practiced.
Jake: 练我
Jake: Practice on me.
Jake: 可以好下去吧
Jake: Alright, let's move on.
Shure:  好然后呢
Shure: Alright, what's next?
Jake: 哈哈哈换下一个
Jake: Hahaha, let's switch to the next one.
Shure:  下一位
Shure: Next one.
Jake: 要拿要帮你拿东西吗
Jake: Do you need me to grab something for you?
Lucia: 好可以的
Lucia: Sure, that's fine.
Lucia: 谢谢嗯
Lucia: Thanks, yeah.
Lucia: 帮我拿一下这个啊
Lucia: Help me grab this.
Lucia: 还有这个
Lucia: And this one.
Lucia: 这怎么整
Lucia: How do I handle this?
Lucia: 就把它扔进去就行了吗
Lucia: Just throw it in?
Jake: 来
Jake: Go ahead.
Jake: 对就越中间越好
Jake: Yes, aim for the center.
Jake: 你还有5秒钟
Jake: You have 5 seconds left.
Lucia: 好像不是那么中间
Lucia: Doesn't seem that centered.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: It's good.
Jake: 那还你还有一次机会
Jake: You still have one more chance.
Jake: 你可以往左边打一打
Jake: You can try aiming to the left.
Tasha: 球
Tasha: Ball
Jake: 球来了
Jake: Ball's coming
Tasha: 补中
Tasha: Hit
Jake: 哈哈哈好
Jake: Hahaha, good
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay
Jake: 来吧
Jake: Come on
Lucia: 谢谢哎哪个是我谢谢
Lucia: Thank you, hey which one is mine, thanks
Jake: 好的
Jake: Got it
Jake: 稳稳健
Jake: Steady
Jake: 极其稳健
Jake: Very steady
Jake: 也有个火鸡
Jake: There's also a turkey
Shure:  strike
Shure: Strike
Jake: 上火鸡就一次
Jake: Only one turkey at a time
Jake: 全砸中就有个火鸡
Jake: Hit them all and you get a turkey
其他人：厉害
Others: Impressive
Jake: 哈哈没关系这左边右边都没有差别
Jake: Haha, it's okay, there's no difference between left and right
Jake: 比你还多比你还多比你还多
Jake: More than you, more than you, more than you
Lucia: 82 哈哈来
Lucia: 82, haha come on
Jake: 越歪分越高你知道不
Jake: The more crooked, the higher the score, you know?
Shure:  来下一位
Shure: Next person
Jake: 来来来来来来
Jake: Come on, come on, come on
Katrina:  咿呀
Katrina: Yay
Shure:  你这好随意啊
Shure: You're so casual
Jake: 哈哈手滑了
Jake: Haha, I slipped
Jake: 还有还有还有
Jake: Again, again, again
Shure:  哎你这
Shure: Hey, you...
Shure:  现实中你这就是Ghetto
Shure: In real life, this is so ghetto
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina:  是一个很随便的人
Katrina: I'm a pretty casual person
Shure:  助跑
Shure: Running start
Jake: 球球来了
Jake: Ball, ball's coming
Jake: 球已经来了
Jake: The ball's already here
Katrina:  哦哦已经来了
Katrina: Oh, oh, it's already here
Shure:  送出去给他
Shure: Send it out to him
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay
Jake: 子韬来
Jake: Zitao, come
Jake: 紫藤来
Jake: Zitong, come
Katrina:  哎哪来的枪哈哈哈
Katrina: Hey, where did the gun come from, hahaha
Jake: 哎怎么这么多
Jake: Hey, why so many?
Shure:  完了要split了
Shure: Done, it's gonna split
Shure:  好全中
Shure: Alright, got them all.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Jake: 还有是吧
Jake: There are more, right?
Jake: 还有克星还有吧
Jake: There are still nemesis, right?
Jake: 还有还有还有可心呢
Jake: More, more, where's Kexin?
Lucia: 哎又出来了
Lucia: Oh, it's out again.
Katrina:  几个币啊
Katrina: How many coins?
Katrina:  玩这么久可以
Katrina: Played for so long, it's okay.
Jake: 呵一个一个一个
Jake: Haha, one by one.
Jake: 你这个带钻的你知道吧
Jake: You know this one has a diamond, right?
Jake: 来把他干掉
Jake: Come on, take him out.
Lucia: 那我就再把这一个打中呗
Lucia: Then I'll hit this one again.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 稳稳健
Jake: Steady.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 他应该会还有一局
Lucia: He should have one more round.
Lucia: 我怎么感觉
Lucia: I feel like...
Jake: 没了没了就结束了
Jake: No more, no more, it's over.
Jake: 好走吧
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Jake: 还有两个币
Jake: There are two more coins.
Jake: 两个币就显身前嘛
Jake: Two coins to show up, right?
Jake: 对对对对显身前
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, to show up.
其他人：这里面是鬼屋
Others: This is a haunted house.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
其他人：我在这边做好久它突然
Others: I've been here for a long time, it suddenly...
Jake: 搞笑
Jake: Funny.
Tasha: 是金钱的声音
Tasha: It's the sound of money.
Jake: 哇
Jake: Wow.
Jake: 天呐
Jake: Oh my god.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  嗯再来一个我们
Shure: Hmm, let's do another one.
Jake: 这是蝴蝶效应
Jake: This is the butterfly effect.
Jake: 在前1秒钟
Jake: In the last second.
Lucia: 然后按一下他才会掉下来
Lucia: Then press it, it'll drop.
Lucia: 按微微按哈哈
Lucia: Press lightly, haha.
Shure:  okay放
Shure: Okay, release.
Katrina:  啊就这么玩吗
Katrina: Are we playing like this?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 走吧哈哈哈
Jake: Let's go, haha.
Jake: 走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Lucia: 我记得小时候
Lucia: I remember when I was little
Lucia: 这个推币机特别容易掉币
Lucia: This coin pusher was really easy to win from
Jake: 怎么还有拍一把
Jake: How come there's still one more push left?
Tasha: 还有它掉下来了
Tasha: And it fell off
Tasha: 啊它掉下来了我刚刚把它拍下来了
Tasha: Oh, it fell off, I just pushed it off
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah
Tasha: 它那怎么不掉呢
Tasha: Why isn't it falling off?
Tasha: 你看我刚刚把它
Tasha: Look, I just
Jake: 我们如果再有一个币他就嗨了
Jake: If we get one more coin, it'll be great
Tasha: 真的吗啊但是没有
Tasha: Really? But we don't have any more
Jake: 但是没有
Jake: But we don't have any
Tasha: 我刚想我不是把它这样拍下来了吗
Tasha: I was just thinking, didn't I just push it down?
Jake: 不是你你拍下来他掉下来
Jake: No, you pushed it down, and it fell
Jake: 但是你投币了他下面的人会开对
Jake: But if you put in a coin, the person below will get it, right?
Tasha: 你看他们选错篮子了
Tasha: Look, they chose the wrong basket
Tasha: 应该让我先把全部的机器拍一拍
Tasha: I should have pushed all the machines first
Tasha: 然后再开始投币
Tasha: And then start putting in coins
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Right, right, right
Jake: 投一个币得一个币哎哎哎
Jake: Put in one coin, get one coin, hey hey hey
Tasha: 哎哎哎
Tasha: Hey hey hey
Tasha: 连吃带拿
Tasha: Eat and take at the same time
Tasha: 刚刚有人问我们在干嘛
Tasha: Someone just asked what we're doing
Tasha: 我说
Tasha: I said
Tasha: 我们是一群机器人在模仿真人生活
Tasha: We're a group of robots imitating human life
Jake: OK OK
Tasha: 你觉得他会相信吗
Tasha: Do you think he believed it?
Jake: 会
Jake: He did
Tasha: 你觉得你相信了吗
Tasha: Do you think you believed it?
Jake: 我信了好
Jake: I believed it, sure
Tasha: 好哈哈
Tasha: Alright, haha
Jake: 我们就是这是
Jake: We really are
Tasha: 我根本就没有跟别人说话
Tasha: I didn't even talk to anyone
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 我只是在模拟万
Tasha: I was just pretending
Tasha: 有人问我们怎么办
Tasha: In case someone asked what we're doing
Jake: 好吧从头就开始这编的
Jake: Alright, starting from the beginning, this is all made up
Lucia: 还有西安博物馆
Lucia: And then there's the Xi'an Museum
Lucia: 但是陕西博好像这两年比较火
Lucia: But Shaanxi Museum has been pretty popular these past two years
Lucia: 然后就特别难约票
Lucia: So it's really hard to get tickets
Lucia: 就要提前几天开始约票才行
Lucia: You have to book tickets a few days in advance
Lucia: 但是这几个
Lucia: But these few
Lucia: 碑林博物馆好像是要门票的
Lucia: The Beilin Museum seems to require tickets.
Tasha: 然后干嘛去
Tasha: Then where are we going?
Tasha: 哎你看我买帽子的地方
Tasha: Oh, look at the place where I bought the hat.
Lucia: 这就是那天那个的green party
Lucia: This is the green party from that day.
Jake: 哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Jake: 挺好玩这些小孩
Jake: These kids are quite fun.
Lucia: 为什么现在会有这么多室内的
Lucia: Why are there so many indoor
Lucia: 这样的篮球场
Lucia: basketball courts now?
Lucia: 篮球不应该在室外打吗
Lucia: Isn't basketball supposed to be played outdoors?
Tasha: 可能帅吧
Tasha: Maybe it's cooler?
Lucia: 哈哈有道理哈哈
Lucia: Haha, makes sense, haha.
Jake: 对是一样
Jake: Yeah, it's the same.
Jake: 能室内就室内
Jake: If we can play indoors, we should.
Tasha: 现在干嘛去
Tasha: What are we doing now?
Jake: 也只能给小孩
Jake: Just for the kids.
Tasha: 怎么人不见了
Tasha: Why are people missing?
Jake: 对啊他们人呢
Jake: Yeah, where did they go?
Lucia: 人呢
Lucia: Where are they?
Jake: 剩下的人去哪了呢
Jake: Where did the rest go?
Tasha: 觉得我们先逛个超市吧
Tasha: I think we should visit a supermarket first.
Jake: 好走走
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Jake: 晃悠晃悠
Jake: Let's wander around.
Jake: 嘿嘿公共switch
Jake: Haha, a public switch.
Alice: 他们是不是去那个好特卖了
Alice: Did they go to that great sale?
Jake: 有可能
Jake: Possibly.
Tasha: 哦果然他们已经开始买了
Tasha: Oh, they are already shopping.
Jake: 好玩吗有肉吗
Jake: Is it fun? Do they have meat?
Shure:  这这是一个
Shure: This is a
Jake: 啥呀这都是
Jake: What is all this?
Shure:  超级特价超市
Shure: A super discount market.
Jake: 噢噢噢
Jake: Oh, oh.
Shure:  杨老板逛过吗
Shure: Have you been here, Jake?
Jake: 没有那
Jake: No, I haven't.
Tasha: 看才三块三
Tasha: Look, only 3.3 yuan.
Shure:  新加坡有有
Shure: Is there something like this in Singapore?
Shure:  有这种的吗
Shure: Do they have this?
Jake: 3块3的牙刷好有
Jake: A 3.3 yuan toothbrush, they do.
Jake: 好像没有一元
Jake: I don't think they have 1 yuan.
Jake: 问到就是那种什么刀了
Jake: Ask about the knives.
Shure:  one dollar这个少是吧对
Shure: One dollar, that's a bit less, right?
Jake:  one dollar那些
Jake: The one dollar ones.
Jake: 都有什么比较优秀的便宜的东西呢
Jake: What good cheap stuff do they have?
Lucia: 不知道我也只逛过一次
Lucia: I don't know, I've only been there once.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 3块9的巴黎矿泉水早上
Jake: That 3.9 dollar Perrier in the morning.
Jake: 应该再整点这个对
Jake: Should get some of that, right?
Lucia: 哦这个这个
Lucia: Oh, this one.
Lucia: 在这里卖的还挺便宜的嘛
Lucia: It's pretty cheap here.
Shure:  为什么啊
Shure: Why?
Lucia: 这在国国内有地方卖老贵
Lucia: It's super expensive in some places back home.
Shure:  确实 12块5呢
Shure: Indeed, it's 12.5 dollars.
Jake: 卖老贵
Jake: Super expensive.
Lucia: 呃卖老贵
Lucia: Yeah, super expensive.
Jake: 哦真的呀 12块5
Jake: Oh really? 12.5 dollars.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Yeah.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm.
Shure:  星巴克那玻璃那个更贵巴黎水
Shure: The Perrier at Starbucks in the glass bottle is even more expensive.
Lucia: oldly
Lucia: Oldly.
Jake: 啊这个些酒是不是也很便宜
Jake: Ah, these wines are also very cheap, right?
Shure:  啊确实
Shure: Yeah, indeed.
Jake: 整两瓶相比比较
Jake: Let's get two bottles to compare.
Shure:  我靠这个香槟只要39块钱
Shure: Wow, this champagne is only 39 dollars.
Shure:  这个气泡酒
Shure: This sparkling wine.
Jake: 心动吗
Jake: Tempted?
Jake: 哎哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 对但是当
Lucia: Yes, but of course,
Lucia: 当然也要看你
Lucia: it also depends on
Lucia: 就是本身葡萄的质量怎么样
Lucia: the quality of the grapes themselves.
Lucia: 但是就是莫斯卡托应该是产地
Lucia: But Moscato should be fine, the origin is good.
Lucia: 就这个地方应该不错了
Lucia: This place should be good.
Shure:  不是有效 2033年
Shure: Isn't it good until 2033?
Lucia: 没事酒酒酒
Lucia: It's fine, wine, wine, wine.
Lucia: 好像没有什么特别特殊的
Lucia: Doesn't seem to have anything special.
Shure:  整整一瓶
Shure: Get a whole bottle.
Jake: 选一品
Jake: Choose one.
Shure:  今天晚上蹦一下好吧
Shure: Let's party tonight, okay?
Jake: 我们好啊
Jake: We're in!
Katrina:  就是可以搞点real不
Katrina: Can we get some real stuff?
Jake: 今晚能蹦吗
Jake: Can we party tonight?
Shure:  可以也可以蹦
Shure: Yeah, we could pop one.
Shure:  因为冰箱里还有一瓶
Shure: Because there's still one in the fridge.
Lucia: 冰箱还有一瓶
Lucia: There's still one in the fridge.
Jake: 那今晚崩一个哦好
Jake: Let's pop one tonight then, alright?
Lucia: 我们那天买了一瓶起泡酒
Lucia: We bought a bottle of sparkling wine the other day.
Shure:  今天晚上蹦一个
Shure: Let's pop one tonight.
Shure:  这个素材得给AI看一下吧
Shure: This content should be reviewed by the AI, right?
Jake: 对 39块钱听个响挺好的
Jake: Yeah, 39 bucks just to hear it pop, pretty good.
Lucia: 哈哈 39块钱听个响
Lucia: Haha, 39 bucks just to hear it pop.
Jake: 对我我我买的那个10个USB的充电器
Jake: Yeah, the USB charger I bought with 10 ports...
Jake: 也3030多块钱一个
Jake: Also cost around 30 bucks each.
Jake: 响也没有就是一点都都充不上
Jake: It didn't make any sound and it didn't charge at all.
Jake: 看起来挺牛逼
Jake: It just looked impressive.
Alice: 起泡酒吗
Alice: The sparkling wine?
Jake: 这好歹能听个响
Jake: At least it makes a sound.
Lucia: 这好奶奶
Lucia: This is so...
Lucia: 听个响
Lucia: Just to hear the sound.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 我跟我朋友第一回开起泡酒的时候
Lucia: The first time my friend and I opened a bottle of sparkling wine...
Lucia: 我们俩打开
Lucia: Let's open it.
Lucia: 不知道接下来怎么处理
Lucia: No idea what to do next
Lucia: 他就放在那
Lucia: He just left it there
Lucia: 就过一会他嘣哈哈哈
Lucia: Then after a while, it went boom, haha
Jake: 哦延时崩
Jake: Oh, delayed boom
Alice: 听个响
Alice: Just for the sound
Jake: 延时听个响
Jake: Delayed sound
Alice: 不放辣椒酱
Alice: No chili sauce
Shure:  还有什么想买的吗Minasa
Shure: Anything else you want to buy, Minasa?
Jake: 还有啥好东西
Jake: Any other good stuff?
Shure:  你知道黄桃黄桃罐头吗
Shure: Do you know about canned yellow peaches?
Jake: 我知道治感冒的
Jake: I know it's for treating colds
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Yeah
Alice: 哈哈哈啊
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina:  买点小零食当那个
Katrina: Buy some snacks for that
Lucia: 啊是真的可以治感冒吗
Lucia: Oh, can it really treat colds?
Jake: 是吗
Jake: Really?
Katrina:  可以买什么
Katrina: What can we buy?
Shure:  在东北可以
Shure: In the northeast, it can
Shure:  在别的地就不灵了
Shure: But not anywhere else
Shure:  这个东西
Shure: This thing.
Jake: 就跟拜佛似的也治感冒
Jake: It's like praying to Buddha can also cure colds.
Shure:  就是这个东西
Shure: It's this thing.
Jake: 拜菩萨也治感冒对
Jake: Praying to Bodhisattvas can also cure colds, right?
Shure:  非非常的违心
Shure: It's very insincere.
Alice: 拜妈祖
Alice: Praying to Mazu.
Alice: 福建的管用
Alice: It works in Fujian.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Right, right.
Katrina:  想买一包咪咪吃
Katrina: I want to buy a pack of Mimi to eat.
Katrina:  就当那个
Katrina: Just as a...
Katrina:  等早饭外卖
Katrina: While waiting for breakfast delivery.
Katrina:  的垫垫肚子那个
Katrina: To fill my stomach a bit.
Jake: 啊行行行
Jake: Ah, okay, okay.
Katrina:  对要是怕有的人胃不舒都行
Katrina: Yeah, in case some people have an upset stomach.
Shure:  这不是野餐零食吗哈哈
Shure: Isn't this a picnic snack? Haha.
Tasha: 噔噔噔这个糖还挺好吃的
Tasha: Ta-da, this candy is pretty tasty.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Shure:  这样我们我们都给杨老板换
Shure: So, we'll exchange everything for Jake.
Shure:  换算成新币
Shure: Exchange it for new currency.
Katrina:  新加坡比
Katrina: Singapore dollars.
Shure:  咱们都对
Shure: Right, for all of us.
Alice: 这样听起来就不心疼了哈哈
Alice: That way it doesn't feel painful, haha.
Jake: 这个太离谱了吧 5毛星
Jake: This is too ridiculous, 50 cents.
Jake: 5毛钱的新币
Jake: 50 cents in new currency.
Jake: 什么东西
Jake: What?
Shure:  3块9就5毛钱是吗
Shure: 3.9 is 50 cents, right?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh.
Jake: 是6毛钱吧
Jake: It's 60 cents, right?
Jake: 是51:五点三吧现在得
Jake: It's 51: 5.3 now.
Shure:  你就除以5减3
Shure: Just divide by 5, minus 3.
Shure:  你大概除以5
Shure: You roughly divide by 5.
Jake: 对给我报新币吧
Jake: Yes, give me the new currency.
Jake: 你这多少钱这
Jake: How much is this?
Shure:  在7新币
Shure: It's 7 in new currency.
Jake: 七星币的酒
Jake: Seven dollars for the wine.
Jake: 这听这这也听
Jake: This, listen, this, listen.
Jake: 呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Shure:  听个响还能
Shure: Just listen to it.
Jake: 还来听个响
Jake: Listen to it.
Jake: 1是米的球
Jake: It's a rice ball.
Lucia: 好像也还行
Lucia: It seems okay too.
Lucia: 奥迪和丽豆里面应该有不少这个价格
Lucia: There should be quite a few at this price in Audi and Lidl.
Lucia: 你们那有奥迪和丽豆
Lucia: Do you have Audi and Lidl there?
Jake: 我们不怎么买不太懂
Jake: We don't really buy them, not too familiar.
Jake: 但是七新币听起来就很便宜
Jake: But seven Singapore dollars sounds pretty cheap.
Alice: 这个牌子小啤酒
Alice: This brand of small beer.
Shure:  懂了懂了
Shure: Got it, got it.
Shure:  这这多少
Shure: How much is this?
Shure:  这不到1新币
Shure: Less than 1 Singapore dollar.
Shure:  这这一袋那什么
Shure: This whole bag of what?
Lucia: 呃body shop是一个英国牌子
Lucia: Uh, Body Shop is a British brand.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 嗯这边破产了
Alice: Hmm, it's bankrupt here.
Shure:  他还拿了一个不到两两毛新币的
Shure: He also took something for less than 0.2 Singapore dollars.
Shure:  一个薄荷糖
Shure: A mint.
Jake: 那随便吧哈哈哈
Jake: Then whatever, haha.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  哇以后就都给杨老板报新币
Shure: Wow, from now on we'll report everything to Jake in Singapore dollars.
Lucia: 不过大概也就5毛新币吧
Lucia: But it's probably around 0.5 Singapore dollars.
Tasha: 按5毛新币
Tasha: At 0.5 Singapore dollars.
Lucia: 5毛新币
Lucia: 0.5 Singapore dollars.
Tasha: 新币币的换算比例是
Tasha: The conversion rate for Singapore dollars is...
Shure:  嗯除以5再抹个0
Shure: Yeah, divide by 5 and round off.
Tasha: 除以5再抹个0
Tasha: Divide by 5 and round off.
Shure:  对他说大概是5.3
Shure: Yeah, they said it's roughly 5.3.
Katrina:  放我这袋里吧
Katrina: Put it in my bag.
Jake: 多少新币
Jake: How much in Singapore dollars?
Jake: 10块
Jake: 10 dollars.
Tasha: 十个金
Tasha: Ten gold coins.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure:  52块4不到1新币
Shure: 52.4 is less than 1 Singapore dollar.
Tasha: 一个金币
Tasha: One gold coin.
Shure:  不行杨老板咱先别换算呵呵
Shure: No, Jake, let's not convert right now, hehe.
Jake: 来来来
Jake: Come on, come on.
Jake: 怎么付啊
Jake: How do we pay?
Katrina:  放我这袋里吧
Katrina: Put it in my bag.
Lucia: 这方法会不会有点重啊
Lucia: Won't this method be a bit heavy?
Katrina:  party没关系
Katrina: No worries, it's a party.
Lucia: 哦你提啊
Lucia: Oh, you carry it.
Lucia: 那那就放了
Lucia: Then, just put it in.
Lucia: 那我就不客气了啊哈哈
Lucia: Then I won't be polite, haha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈没事
Katrina: Hahaha, it's okay.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Tasha: have that
Tasha: Have that.
Shure:  留好小票子
Shure: Keep the receipt.
Alice: 是为了两盒
Alice: It's for two boxes.
Katrina:  走吧盒马在哪呢
Katrina: Let's go, where's Hema?
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 来干正事吧
Jake: Let's get down to business.
Jake: 可以哎我看看还能录多久啊
Jake: Okay, let me see how much longer we can record.
Alice: 啊一个小时
Alice: About an hour.
Jake: 行那正好
Jake: Alright, perfect.
Jake: 正事能干一小时吗
Jake: Can we do the business in an hour?
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 这事是指买烤肉吗
Lucia: Is this about buying BBQ meat?
Jake: 买肉买肉可能用不着一小时
Jake: Buying meat shouldn't take an hour.
Katrina:  还要下去嘞
Katrina: We still need to go downstairs.
Shure:  还要下去吗
Shure: We need to go downstairs?
Jake: 买肉用不着一小时
Jake: Buying meat won't take an hour.
Jake: 再晃一晃
Jake: Let's stroll around.
Jake: 哈哈行吧行吧
Jake: Haha, okay, okay.
Lucia: 把肉围起来观察
Lucia: Surround the meat and observe it.
Shure:  可是我们我们一会那个切肉什么的
Shure: But we need to, like, cut the meat later.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure:  要要要
Shure: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake: 他当场切肉是吗
Jake: You cut the meat on the spot?
Shure:  不是我回去处理的时候
Shure: No, I'll handle it when we get back.
Lucia: 你当场切肉你当
Lucia: You cut the meat on the spot, you...
Jake: 你回去处理
Jake: You handle it when we get back.
Jake: 充完电了就重来了
Jake: Once it's charged, we'll restart.
Jake: 就重来了呀
Jake: We'll restart, yeah.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Yeah.
Jake: 就不是这一波了
Jake: So it's not this round.
Tasha: 哦我已经看到他了
Tasha: Oh, I can see him.
Jake: 数据倒完了
Jake: The data is done.
Shure:  我也看到他了
Shure: I can see him too.
Shure:  我看到了他的倒影
Shure: I see his reflection.
Jake: 谁啊哦
Jake: Who? Oh.
Shure:  在反转世界在镜花水月中
Shure: In the reverse world, in the mirror illusion.
Shure:  我已经看到了他
Shure: I can see him.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Tasha: 好吧什么都不是
Tasha: Okay, it's nothing.
Shure:  when
Shure: when
Shure:  要不给他给大家喂个剪头素材
Shure: How about we give him some clip material for everyone?
Shure:  我牺牲一下
Shure: I'll sacrifice myself.
Alice: 生瓜子的味道
Alice: Raw sunflower seeds smell.
Alice: 炒瓜子啊
Alice: Roasted sunflower seeds.
Jake: 嗯糊了炒糊了
Jake: Yeah, it's burnt, over-roasted.
Alice: 炒货
Alice: Roasted snacks.
Tasha: 拿拿车车呀
Tasha: Take the cart.
Jake: 好糊啊
Jake: So burnt.
Jake: 几车一车够了吧
Jake: How many carts do we need, one enough?
Jake: 大家就觉得北京只有盒马
Jake: Everyone thinks Beijing only has Hema.
Tasha: 还有山姆物美
Tasha: There's also Sam's Club and Wu Mart.
Jake: 哦OK
Jake: Oh, okay.
Tasha: 是不是要买很多羊肉粒牛肉粒
Tasha: Do we need to buy a lot of lamb cubes and beef cubes?
Lucia: 突然发现忘记推迟
Lucia: Suddenly realized I forgot to postpone.
Alice: 他是不是还要买枪啊
Alice: Does he still need to buy a gun?
Tasha: 签谁买了呗你不说
Tasha: Who bought the sign? You didn't say.
Jake: 哦是那边有吧估计
Jake: Oh, it's probably over there.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Lucia: 可能有一次性的那种竹签对
Lucia: Maybe there's the disposable bamboo skewers.
Alice: 中间有没有直接带签的
Jake: 签签签怎么整啊
Jake: How do we handle the skewers?
Shure:  这显得就很没用你知道吗
Shure: It seems so useless, you know?
Jake: 闲着用啊
Jake: Just use it.
Jake: 那你干啥呀
Jake: Then what are you doing?
Lucia: 这有穿好的还有签
Lucia: There are pre-threaded ones and skewers.
Jake: 哈哈哈没有签
Jake: Haha, no skewers.
Lucia: 所有的问题都解决了
Lucia: All problems solved.
Shure:  不咱们买点鸡翅
Shure: No, let's get some chicken wings.
Shure:  我腌的鸡翅特别好吃
Shure: My marinated chicken wings are delicious.
Jake: 行整点整点
Jake: Alright, get some.
Tasha: 这个要拿吗
Tasha: Should we get this?
Shure:  也拿点这个
Shure: Let's get some of this too.
Jake: 拿点拿点拿点
Jake: Get some, get some.
Shure:  好吧就是咱们得保证一个饿不死的
Shure: Okay, we just need to make sure we have enough food.
Shure:  一个食食物
Shure: Some food.
Shure:  然后在在死之上
Shure: And above that...
Lucia: 啊这是羊排吗
Lucia: Oh, is this lamb chops?
Shure:  我靠羊排
Shure: Wow, lamb chops.
Jake: 啥呀
Jake: What?
Shure:  然后可以憋
Shure: And then you can hold your breath.
Tasha: 一个新币
Tasha: One new coin.
Tasha: 加起来一共两个新币
Tasha: Altogether, that's two new coins.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Alice: 1010点
Alice: 1010 points.
Jake: 买买两个新币在新加坡就有半根串
Jake: Buying two new coins in Singapore gets you half a skewer.
Katrina:  真的吗这么贵
Katrina: Really? That expensive?
Jake: 哈哈真的是的
Jake: Haha, yes, really.
Shure:  五十新币
Shure: Fifty new coins.
Shure:  你怎么算的哈哈
Shure: How did you calculate that? Haha.
Katrina:  一个新币换算成人民币是50块钱吗要
Katrina: Does one new coin convert to 50 RMB?
Jake: 4新币 4新币
Jake: 4 new coins, 4 new coins.
Jake: 5对5.3
Jake: 5 to 5.3.
Lucia: 哈 5比5点多
Lucia: Ha, 5 to over 5.
Alice: 5点多
Alice: Over 5.
Jake: 对大概一根串
Jake: Yeah, about one skewer.
Jake: 就牛肉串
Jake: Just a beef skewer.
Jake: 这种牛肉串
Jake: This kind of beef skewer.
Jake: 大概就是哎这种串
Jake: It's roughly like, hey, this kind of skewer.
Jake: 一一新币一个哦
Jake: One new coin for one skewer.
Jake: 一新币一串
Jake: One new coin per skewer.
Jake: 对一新币一串
Jake: Yeah, one new coin per skewer.
Jake: 位置好一点就两心闭一串
Jake: If the location is better, it's two coins per skewer.
Shure:  不行我这不不需要不需要
Shure: No, I don't need this, don't need this.
Shure:  咱们不用这些
Shure: We don't need these.
Shure:  这这些肯定不好吃
Shure: These definitely don't taste good.
Katrina:  你有自己独家配方来腌吗
Katrina: Do you have your own secret marinade recipe?
Katrina:  还是怎么
Katrina: Or what?
Shure:  是的祖传十八辈了已经
Shure: Yes, it's been passed down for eighteen generations.
Katrina:  那你需要买什么调料吗
Katrina: Do you need to buy any spices?
Lucia: 瓜子大礼包
Lucia: A big bag of sunflower seeds.
Jake: 哎肉买完了吗
Jake: Hey, did you finish buying the meat?
Jake: 还没开始呢
Jake: Haven't started yet.
Lucia: 内含三种口味
Lucia: It has three flavors.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 瓜子
Jake: Sunflower seeds.
Lucia: 我也想知道
Lucia: I also want to know.
Lucia: 世界好店
Lucia: The best store in the world.
Lucia: 藤椒味的瓜子
Lucia: Sichuan pepper flavored sunflower seeds.
Shure:  那个很好吃
Shure: That is delicious.
Katrina:  之前藤椒冰淇淋呢
Katrina: What about the rattan pepper ice cream we had before?
Shure:  巨好吃那个藤藤椒
Shure: That rattan pepper was super tasty.
Katrina:  麦当劳这边出在四川限定
Katrina: McDonald's released it as a Sichuan exclusive.
Shure:  那个瓜子
Shure: Those seeds...
Lucia: 麦当劳是有什
Lucia: What's with McDonald's?
Lucia: 麦当劳你有什么心事吗
Lucia: McDonald's, do you have any concerns?
Shure:  藤椒味的瓜子
Shure: Rattan pepper flavored seeds.
Jake: 藤椒瓜藤椒冰淇淋
Jake: Rattan pepper seeds, rattan pepper ice cream.
Jake: 藤椒瓜子
Jake: Rattan pepper seeds.
Katrina:  之前麦当劳出过在四川限定
Katrina: McDonald's released it before as a Sichuan exclusive.
Jake: 藤椒冰淇淋我靠
Jake: Rattan pepper ice cream, oh my god.
Katrina:  就是还浇那个辣子油
Katrina: They even poured spicy oil on it.
Katrina:  crazy
Katrina: Crazy.
Shure:  一斤多可以羊排
Shure: More than a pound of lamb chops.
Katrina:  这是什么呀羊排
Katrina: What is this? Lamb chops?
Jake: 来放进去放进去
Jake: Come on, put it in, put it in.
Shure:  来我需要洋葱调料串
Shure: I need onions, seasoning skewers.
Jake: 块那个竹签怎么整
Jake: How should we handle the bamboo skewers?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 竹签竹签儿
Jake: Bamboo skewers, bamboo skewers.
Shure:  呃烤的那个
Shure: Uh, the grilled ones.
Shure:  直接用这个
Shure: Just use this.
Shure:  然后不穿
Shure: And don't skewer it.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  咱们就烤片
Shure: We'll just grill slices.
Shure:  然后腌好
Shure: Then marinate it.
Shure:  然后烤片可以吧
Shure: Then grill the slices, okay?
Jake: 行行行不要签了
Jake: Sure, sure, no skewers.
Alice: 有那个夹子吗 反面的
Alice: Do you have those clips for turning?
Shure:  啊对好问题
Shure: Ah, good question.
Shure:  咱们再补个夹子
Shure: Let's add some clips.
Alice: 沙子跟油
Alice: Sand and oil.
Shure:  好问题啊
Shure: Good question.
Shure:  有有刷子刷子也有刷刷子
Shure: We have brushes too, for brushing.
Alice: 孜然
Alice: Cumin.
Shure:  你那天哎那谁呢
Shure: The other day, hey, where's that person?
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Right, right, right.
Jake: 就是公寓
Jake: It's the apartment.
Shure:  那个
Shure: That...
Jake: 在别墅里面有是吧
Jake: There's one in the villa, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
其他人：应该有
Others: There should be.
Jake: 别说有那夹子哈
Jake: Don't tell me there's a clip.
Shure:  啊OK
Shure: Ah, OK.
其他人：那这种就是要要个铁盘吗
Others: So do we need an iron plate for this?
Alice: 吃筷子也能
Alice: You can use chopsticks too.
Shure:  我为什么要拎着他呀我靠
Shure: Why do I have to carry him, geez.
Shure:  还想起来
Shure: And then it hits me.
Shure:  我还傻傻地拎着他
Shure: I was stupidly carrying him around.
Shure:  这时候就应该向他问一个问题
Shure: At this point, I should have asked him a question.
Shure:  为什么我有一个车而不放进去
Shure: Why do I have a car but didn't put it in?
Jake: 他花了多长时间意识到这个问题
Jake: How long did it take him to realize this?
Shure:  对他花了
Shure: Yeah, it took him...
Shure:  我花了多久意识到这个问题
Shure: How long did it take me to realize this?
Shure: 迪士尼
Shure: Disney.
其他人：在这里就会觉得它是一个骗钱的
Others: Here, it feels like a money trap.
Jake: 啊啊确实很贵啊
Jake: Ah, it really is expensive.
Jake: 75
Jake: 75.
Lucia: 十十五星期
Lucia: Ten weeks.
Jake: 初代
Jake: The first generation.
Jake: 也也挺贵的
Jake: It's also quite expensive.
Shure:  没有看到鸡翅吗
Shure: Didn't you see the chicken wings?
Lucia: 我每次刚出去的时候就会
Lucia: Every time I go out...
Lucia: 每次看到东西都会转成人民币对
Lucia: I always convert things to RMB.
Jake: 哦转对转回来然后回国了
Jake: Oh, convert back and then return home.
Lucia: 然后回国就问
Lucia: Then ask when I get back...
Jake: 对对对对对
Jake: Right, right, right.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 所以我上次在上海的时候惊讶的发现
Lucia: So last time when I was in Shanghai, I was surprised to find...
Lucia: 上海东西竟然没比英国便宜多少
Lucia: Things in Shanghai aren't much cheaper than in the UK.
Jake: 哦是啊是吧
Jake: Oh, really?
Lucia: 好多东西嗯
Lucia: A lot of things, yeah.
Lucia: 也可能我老去立冬和奥迪a
Lucia: Maybe because I often go to Lidong and Audi A.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 这段删掉
Lucia: Delete that part.
Lucia: 听起来我生活的好好悲惨
Lucia: It makes my life sound so miserable.
Jake: 7块九两瓶
Jake: 7.9 for two bottles.
Alice: 请问鸡翅在哪里
Alice: Excuse me, where are the chicken wings?
Jake: 海参这
Jake: The sea cucumber is here.
Jake: 149
Jake: 149.
Lucia: 149的是加拿大学系
Lucia: The 149 one is from Canada.
Lucia: 海参是39块9100克哎
Lucia: The sea cucumber is 39 dollars for 9100 grams.
Jake: 39
Jake: 39.
Lucia: 如果是冻鲜的那还挺便宜的嘞
Lucia: If it's frozen fresh, that's quite cheap.
Lucia: 暗示的眼神
Lucia: Suggestive look.
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我开玩笑的
Lucia: I'm just kidding.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 我在想这
Jake: I was thinking...
Jake: 东西怎么吃
Jake: How to eat this.
Jake: 早上可以吃
Jake: You can eat it in the morning.
Jake: 但是不知道怎么吃
Jake: But I don't know how to eat it.
Lucia: 一般就是煲汤喝吧
Lucia: Usually, you make soup with it.
Jake: 世界
Jake: World...
Lucia: 不过我觉得
Lucia: But I think...
Lucia: 咱们肯定也没有多余的时间
Lucia: We definitely don't have extra time.
Jake: 啊对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 很用心的去包他
Lucia: To put a lot of effort into making it.
Jake: 对煲汤
Jake: Yeah, soup.
Lucia: 因为那种就是干的再泡发的海参
Lucia: Because that's dried sea cucumber rehydrated.
Jake: 推过去
Jake: Push it over.
Jake: 哈哈哈没有没有因为不够了
Jake: Hahaha, no, because it's not enough.
Tasha: 猜猜为什么要买鸡蛋
Tasha: Guess why we need to buy eggs.
Tasha: 对因为鸡蛋消耗比例太大啊
Tasha: Yeah, because the egg consumption is too high.
Lucia: 哦那天
Lucia: Oh, that day...
Jake: 今天还要做甜点
Jake: We need to make dessert today.
Lucia: 今天还要做甜点
Lucia: We need to make dessert today.
Jake: 你要多少
Jake: How many do you need?
Tasha: 啊鸡蛋吗
Tasha: Ah, eggs?
Jake: 啊你要
Jake: Yeah, how many do you need?
Tasha: 一次甜品可能要10个鸡蛋吧
Tasha: For one dessert, maybe 10 eggs.
Jake: 你还缺多少啊
Jake: How many are you short?
Jake: 好嘞你还缺什么吗
Jake: Okay, what else do you need?
Tasha: 你缺什么吗
Tasha: Do you need anything else?
Jake: 今儿
Jake: Today...
Tasha: 我不缺什么
Tasha: I don't need anything else.
Lucia: 今天这个应该够
Lucia: This should be enough for today.
Jake: 今天做什么呀
Jake: What are we doing today?
Lucia: 哪怕在就是意外消耗应该也够了
Lucia: Even if we have some unexpected consumption, it should still be enough.
Tasha: 今天做什么
Tasha: What are we doing today?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 都可以啊
Tasha: Anything is fine.
Jake: oh好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Tasha: 你想吃什么
Tasha: What do you want to eat?
Jake: 那就选一个
Jake: Let's pick one then.
Jake: 在众多图片里边选一个
Jake: Choose one from all these pictures.
Tasha: 买点sweet drink吧
Tasha: How about buying some sweet drinks?
Lucia: 我我的本体是一只树懒
Lucia: My true form is a sloth.
Tasha: 他更像
Tasha: He looks more like one.
Jake: 动作太快了
Jake: Moving too fast.
Jake: 我怎么就树懒了呀
Jake: How am I a sloth?
Lucia: 没有他是卡皮吧啦
Lucia: No, he's a capybara.
Jake: 那是啥
Jake: What's that?
Lucia: 情绪稳定啊
Lucia: Calm and composed.
Lucia: 你不知道这个梗吗
Lucia: Haven't you heard of this joke?
Jake: 不知道
Jake: No idea.
Lucia: 这是水豚
Lucia: It's a capybara.
Lucia: 是一种很可爱的动物
Lucia: It's a very cute animal.
Shure:  happy吧啦
Shure: Happy bara.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 然后他就是情绪特别稳定
Lucia: And it's super calm.
Lucia: 就是即使电脑的电线断了
Lucia: Even if the computer's power cord breaks,
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 他也能就是情绪稳定的按住
Lucia: It remains calm until the problem is solved.
Lucia: 直到把问题解决为止
Lucia: Stays composed no matter what.
Tasha: 安排
Tasha: Got it.
Shure:  可以烤点
Shure: We could grill something.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  想想啊咱们是7个人
Shure: Thinking for 7 people.
Jake: 这样你吃不了
Jake: This way, you won't eat.
Jake: 其他人：
Jake: Others:
其他人：那我就走了
Others: Then I'll leave.
Shure:  是7个人吃是吧
Shure: It's 7 people eating, right?
Tasha: 那要不要买那个烤料
Tasha: Should we get some barbecue seasoning?
Tasha: 烤烧烤料
Tasha: Barbecue seasoning.
Shure:  是的我先算一下肉要多些
Shure: Yes, I'll calculate first, we need more meat.
Shure:  这么多鸡蛋
Shure: So many eggs.
Lucia: 这薇薇要做甜点要用
Lucia: Tasha needs them to make dessert.
Shure:  啊那一会借我两个
Shure: Ah, then lend me two later.
Tasha: 不借哈哈哈哈
Tasha: No way, haha.
Lucia: 哦你要糊那个啥是吗
Lucia: Oh, are you coating something?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  要要腌的话会
Shure: Yes, if we marinate it.
Lucia: 要腌哦OK
Lucia: We need to marinate it? OK.
Tasha: 东西要用嗯
Tasha: Things need to be used, hmm.
Lucia: 我以为要往上面果汁嘞
Lucia: I thought you were going to add juice on top.
Tasha: 洋葱在这里就有
Tasha: The onions are right here.
Lucia: 洋葱在这里就有
Alice: 在那呢
Alice: Over there.
Jake: 哦真远
Jake: Oh, it's really far.
Shure:  我要紫皮洋葱
Shure: I want the red onions.
Shure:  紫皮洋葱
Shure: Red onions.
Jake: 这个很紫啊
Jake: This one's really red.
Lucia: 紫的这种的呗
Lucia: The purple ones, right?
Jake: 这边啊
Jake: Over here.
其他人：这个有机的
Others: This one is organic.
Jake: 有机多少钱
Jake: How much is organic?
Tasha: 没关系我们就吃贵的
Tasha: It doesn't matter, we'll just eat the expensive ones.
Lucia: 要大的还是小的
Lucia: Do you want big ones or small ones?
Jake: 有机多少钱
Jake: How much is organic?
Tasha: 我觉得要小的比较
Tasha: I think small ones are better.
Shure:  organic
Shure: Organic.
Tasha: 呃要三个小的比较好
Tasha: Uh, three small ones would be better.
Tasha: 这样子的话就不会浪费
Tasha: That way, we won't waste any.
Lucia: 400克
Lucia: 400 grams.
Shure:  100克五块九
Shure: 100 grams for 5.9.
Lucia: 5块9 这个是那个类
Lucia: 5.9, this is that type.
Jake: 这多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Shure:  一新币这个
Shure: This is one Singapore dollar.
Jake: 这多少钱半新币
Jake: How much is this? Half a Singapore dollar?
Shure:  4块3 我们差别
Shure: 4.3, we have a difference.
Jake: 没差别
Jake: No difference.
Alice: 1不到1
Alice: Less than 1.
Jake: 那没差别
Jake: No difference then.
Jake: 有机
Jake: Organic.
Shure:  没差别
Shure: No difference.
Tasha: 没差别
Tasha: No difference.
Jake: 哈哈啊就差一块钱
Jake: Haha, it's just a one yuan difference.
Shure:  啊但是这个比那个轻 100克
Shure: Ah, but this one is 100 grams lighter.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  够了这些
Shure: These are enough.
Shure:  然后肉的话
Shure: And then for the meat...
Alice: 土豆什么吗
Alice: What about potatoes?
Alice: 土豆生菜
Alice: Potatoes and lettuce.
Shure:  然后底下那些串
Shure: And those skewers at the bottom.
Alice: 生菜
Alice: Lettuce.
Shure:  然后也也有肉是不
Shure: And there's meat too, right?
Jake:看买
Jake: Let's see what to buy.
Tasha: 有没有缺的人呀
Tasha: Is anyone missing?
Jake: 我们回去之后
Jake: After we go back...
Jake: 呃哪一个小时用来给我传数据了
Jake: Which hour will you use to send me the data?
Shure:  立即传
Shure: Send it immediately.
Lucia: 刚回去的那个小时吧
Lucia: How about the hour right after we get back?
Jake: 立即传啊
Jake: Send it immediately?
Shure:  对然后因为我们要处理这些的
Shure: Yes, because we need to process these.
Shure:  就也要也要拍一下了是吧
Shure: So we also need to take a picture, right?
Jake: OK那对对是的
Jake: OK, right, right.
Jake: 所以回去之后先放冰箱就给我传是吗
Jake: So after we go back, put it in the fridge first and then send it to me, right?
Jake: 要放冰箱吗
Jake: Does it need to go in the fridge?
Shure:  也其实也
Shure: Actually, it...
Lucia: 放冰箱要拍吗
Lucia: Do we need to take a picture of it in the fridge?
Jake: 要拍放一下吧放一下吧
Jake: Just put it in, and then we can start cutting, right?
Lucia: 要拍那就放啊
Lucia: If we need to take a picture, then put it in.
Jake: 放下等着然后开始切是吧
Jake: Put it in, wait, and then start cutting, right?
Shure:  咱们7个人吧不是
Shure: We have 7 people, right?
Shure:  没有主食
Shure: No staple food.
Shure:  对不吃主食
Shure: Yeah, no staple food.
Lucia: 不是土土土豆
Lucia: Isn't potato a staple food?
Jake: 有有土豆
Jake: We have potatoes.
Lucia: 那土豆也算是一种主食
Lucia: Then potatoes count as a staple food.
Lucia: 因为主要主要成分是淀粉对吧
Lucia: Because they are mainly starch, right?
Lucia: 强词夺理
Jake: 哈哈哈哈是主食
Jake: Hahaha, it is a staple food.
Jake: 确实是主食
Jake: It really is a staple food.
Jake: 土豆泥对吧
Jake: Mashed potatoes, right?
Lucia: 对哦
Lucia: Oh right
其他人：要不拿个面包片啊
Others: How about getting a slice of bread?
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Jake: 面包片做早饭是吧
Jake: Bread slices for breakfast, right?
Jake: 明明天做个早饭吧
Jake: Let's make breakfast tomorrow morning
其他人：烤了好吃
Others: It's delicious when toasted
Jake: 啊好好
Jake: Ah, okay, okay
其他人：你吃烧烤吃少了你不懂的要选什么菜
Others: You don't eat enough BBQ to know what to pick
Jake: 哈哈哈现在点菜
Jake: Hahaha, ordering food now
Jake: 其实点菜还要吃什么烧烤
Jake: Actually, why order food when we can have BBQ?
其他人：对呀
Others: Yeah
Katrina:  有水果吗
Katrina: Do we have any fruit?
Katrina:  再买一个
Katrina: Let's buy one more
Lucia: 那我们要不买买点什么水果好啊
Lucia: So should we buy some fruit?
Katrina:  买点好剥的
Katrina: Buy something easy to peel
Jake: 看中啥了呀看中啥了呀
Jake: What caught your eye?
Tasha: 他不帮我切
Tasha: He won't help me cut it
Tasha: 我不要了
Tasha: I don't want it anymore
Jake: 好的他为什么不帮你切这
Jake: Okay, why won't he help you cut it?
Jake: 瓜为什么这么方啊
Jake: Why is this melon so square?
Tasha: 这有半个的
Tasha: There's a half one here
Jake: 这瓜为什么这么方啊
Jake: Why is this melon so square?
Tasha: 他长得开心吧
Tasha: Maybe it grew happily
Jake: 好丑啊
Jake: It's so ugly
Jake: 半个颜色一般哦
Jake: Half of it looks average
Tasha: 但不知道没切开
Tasha: But we don't know until it's cut open
Jake: 但这个好大呀
Jake: But this one is so big
Tasha: 你买吗
Tasha: Are you buying it?
Jake: 山竹
Jake: Mangosteen
Tasha: 20块钱
Tasha: 20 yuan
Jake: 20块钱
Jake: 20 yuan
Jake: 可以买
Jake: That's affordable
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah
Tasha: 但我不吃
Tasha: But I don't eat it
Tasha: 你可以买
Tasha: You can buy it
Tasha: 他们可能也吃
Tasha: They might eat it too
Jake: 那我买一个吧
Jake: Then I'll buy one
Tasha: 好你会挑吗
Tasha: Okay, do you know how to pick?
Jake: 哟我我我就知道
Jake: Oh, I just know
Jake: 挑大的好
Jake: Pick the big ones
Tasha: 我觉得这个好
Tasha: I think this one is good.
Jake: 行听你的
Jake: Alright, we'll go with your choice.
Tasha: 因为我觉得这个7个
Tasha: Because I think these 7 are good.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 那你还要别的水果吗
Jake: Do you want any other fruits?
Tasha: 我不要了
Tasha: No, I don't need any more.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 他们人呢
Tasha: Where are they?
Jake: 他们人呢
Jake: Where are they?
Tasha: 去买小甜水吧
Tasha: Maybe they went to buy some drinks.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 吃榴莲吗
Tasha: Do you want to eat durian?
Jake: 榴莲披萨
Jake: Durian pizza.
Jake: 可以吃榴莲
Jake: We can eat durian.
Tasha: 榴莲你不吃啊
Tasha: You don't eat durian?
Jake: 榴莲也可以吃榴莲
Jake: I can eat durian too.
Jake: 可以吃但是
Jake: I can eat it, but...
Jake: 买吧98可以
Jake: Buy it, 98 is fine.
Tasha: 要不有那种小的
Tasha: Or maybe there's a smaller one.
Shure:  也不行得需要料酒
Shure: No, we need cooking wine.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Tasha: 小的
Tasha: A smaller one.
Jake: 哦榴莲可以吃吗
Jake: Oh, can we eat durian?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 小的是什么
Jake: What's the smaller one?
Tasha: 看到这里有一个这个
Tasha: I saw one here.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 嗯你吃的话就可以买一盒
Tasha: Yeah, if you eat it, we can buy a box.
Tasha: 我吃的话就可以买一盒
Tasha: If I eat it, we can buy a box.
Jake: 好那就买一盒
Jake: Okay, then let's buy a box.
Tasha: 因为好像只有两个人吃
Tasha: Because it seems like only two people will eat.
Tasha: 今天中午的榴莲披萨
Tasha: Today's lunch is durian pizza.
Jake: 哦这么回事啊
Jake: Oh, that's what it is.
Tasha: 哈哈他们都不吃
Tasha: Haha, they all don't eat it.
Jake: 那买吧买吧买吧好的
Jake: Then let's buy it, buy it, buy it, it's fine.
Tasha: 那就买两个嘛
Tasha: Then let's buy two.
Tasha: 好呀
Tasha: Alright.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 他们在哪呢
Jake: Where are they?
Jake: 你的小甜水呢
Jake: Where's your sweet drink?
Tasha: 这呢
Tasha: Here it is.
Tasha: 哎我看到学姐了
Tasha: Hey, I see our senior.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 我听说这个很好喝
Tasha: I've heard this is really good.
Tasha: 就是我在想买大瓶的还是买这样子的
Tasha: I'm just wondering if I should buy a big bottle or this size.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 所以呢
Tasha: So?
Jake: 买大瓶的吧
Jake: Go for the big bottle.
Tasha: 那就买一瓶吧
Tasha: Then let's get one bottle.
Jake: 对小瓶的
Jake: Yeah, the small bottle.
Jake: 不知道谁是喝不完的
Jake: Don't know who can't finish it.
Jake: 大瓶的能喝完
Jake: The big bottle can be finished.
Tasha: 买什么
Tasha: Buy what?
Jake: 买帝王蟹啊
Jake: Buy king crab.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake: 没有买买油买油
Jake: No, buy oil, buy oil.
Tasha: 可是不是有玉米油吗
Tasha: But don't we have corn oil?
Tasha: 玉米油不符合他们的要求是吧
Tasha: Corn oil doesn't meet their requirements, right?
Tasha: 泡茶的水
Tasha: Water for tea.
Jake: 哎呀不好意思撞到你了
Jake: Oh sorry, I bumped into you.
Jake: 你去新加坡
Jake: You going to Singapore?
Jake: 上次谢斌竹去就哎
Jake: Last time Xie Binzhu went, oh
Jake: 不是大龙虾是大螃蟹
Jake: It wasn't lobster, it was big crab.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 去去新里吃
Jake: Go, go eat at Xinli.
Jake: 100新币 100新币一只
Jake: 100 SGD, 100 SGD each.
Jake: 哈哈哈还行吧
Jake: Hahaha, it's okay, right?
Jake: 100新币一只
Jake: 100 SGD each.
Jake: 这个多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me see.
Lucia: 是是那天那个1,600块钱的帝王蟹吗
Lucia: Is it that 1,600 RMB king crab?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈不是
Jake: Hahaha, no.
Lucia: 还是啥
Lucia: Or what?
Shure:  哎波龙才469啊
Shure: Hey, Boston lobster is only 469 RMB.
Shure:  换算除5的话不到100新币
Shure: If you convert it, it's less than 100 SGD.
Shure:  90都不到
Shure: Not even 90.
Jake: 波龙还是波龙不应该这么贵
Jake: Boston lobster shouldn't be that expensive.
Lucia: 哎我也想说
Lucia: Hey, I thought so too.
Lucia: 其实波龙在国内还挺贵的
Lucia: Actually, lobsters are quite expensive in our country.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 波龙在波士顿就十十美元
Jake: Lobsters in Boston are just ten dollars.
Jake: 10美元一只
Jake: Ten dollars each.
Lucia: 哦那比在比在伦敦还便宜
Lucia: Oh, that's cheaper than in London.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake: 当时吃了一周就天天的买
Jake: I ate them every day for a week.
Jake: 然后吃腻了
Jake: And got tired of them.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 听起来很爽的亚子
Lucia: Sounds awesome.
Jake: 是的是的
Jake: It is, it is.
Lucia: 伦敦大概15磅
Lucia: In London, it's about 15 pounds.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 啊我喜欢这个
Lucia: Ah, I like this.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Shure:  茴香和孜然是一个东西吗
Shure: Are fennel and cumin the same thing?
Jake: 还缺什么呀
Jake: What else do we need?
Shure:  还缺孜然
Shure: We still need cumin.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 明早让他们做个早饭
Jake: Let's make breakfast tomorrow morning.
Jake: 明早你们做个早饭吧
Jake: You guys make breakfast tomorrow morning.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Okay.
Jake: 啊明早会做
Jake: Oh, breakfast will be ready.
Jake: 明天明早做早饭吧
Jake: Let's make breakfast tomorrow morning.
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Sure.
Lucia: 可以做我们刚才是不是买了面包
Lucia: Can we make it? Did we just buy bread?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 还是怎么回事来着
Lucia: Or what's the deal?
Jake: 对面包是要烤的啊还没对
Jake: Yes, the bread needs to be toasted, right?
Alice: 面包还没买呢
Alice: We haven't bought the bread yet.
Katrina:  买个面包搞点番茄酱就行了
Katrina: Just buy some bread and get some ketchup.
Tasha: 后再买点生菜
Tasha: And buy some lettuce.
Tasha: 直接做个三明治
Tasha: We'll make sandwiches directly.
Alice: 刚才有但是不知道够不够
Alice: We had some before but not sure if it's enough.
Jake: 明天就在
Jake: Tomorrow we'll just
Jake: 就就在屋里待着了
Jake: stay indoors all day.
Jake: 跳跳舞什么的
Jake: Maybe dance a bit.
Jake: 然后如果快递到了就整一整
Jake: And if the delivery arrives, we'll handle it.
Katrina:  对明天主要快递会很多
Katrina: Yeah, there will be a lot of packages tomorrow.
Lucia: 到这个我的快递为什么还没到
Lucia: Why hasn't my package arrived yet?
Lucia: 我在京东上买的东西
Lucia: I bought something on JD.com.
Lucia: 应该今天到啊
Lucia: It should be here today.
其他人：我差不多该走了我要回去拿东西
Others: I should get going, I need to go pick up something.
Jake: 好行行好的
Jake: Alright, sure, sure, okay.
其他人：那我自己先走还是
Others: Should I go by myself then?
Jake: 好可以好
Jake: Yes, that's fine.
其他人：OK那我先走
Others: Okay, I'll head out first then.
Katrina:  你要回去啊
Katrina: Are you heading back?
其他人：对我要赶紧回去了
Others: Yeah, I need to hurry back.
Tasha: 路过别墅拿东西吗
Tasha: Are you passing by the villa to get something?
Katrina:  打卡吗
Katrina: To clock in?
Katrina:  拜拜拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Jake: 周日见周日来是吧
Jake: See you on Sunday, you're coming on Sunday, right?
其他人：周日见
Others: See you on Sunday.
Jake: 拜拜
Jake: Bye.
Shure:  那是咱们是6个人啊
Shure: So there are six of us?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 怎么
Jake: What's up?
Shure:  那没事吃不了
Shure: Never mind, we can't finish it.
Shure:  周日再弄吧
Shure: Let's deal with it on Sunday.
Jake: 对可以好
Jake: Yeah, that's fine.
Shure:  没事了没事
Shure: It's alright, no worries.
Jake: 拜拜
Jake: Bye.
Katrina:  拜拜
Katrina: Bye.
Shure:  哇你还买冰淇淋了
Shure: Wow, you even bought ice cream.
Shure:  孜然哥我们还需要孜然
Shure: We still need cumin, bro.
Lucia: 呃在配送途中
Lucia: Uh, it's on its way.
Katrina:  这是孜然啊
Katrina: Is this cumin?
Shure:  这是孜然粉
Shure: This is cumin powder.
Shure:  不是孜然
Shure: Not cumin seeds.
Katrina:  孜然和孜然粉有什么区别
Katrina: What's the difference between cumin and cumin powder?
Alice: 我们还有白胡椒
Alice: We still have white pepper.
Katrina:  孜然和孜然粉有什么区别
Katrina: What's the difference between cumin and cumin powder?
Lucia: 我喜欢这个
Lucia: I like this one.
Alice: 辣椒粉辣椒面
Alice: Chili powder, chili flakes.
Katrina:  买面包了吗
Katrina: Did you buy bread?
Katrina:  没有是吧
Katrina: No, right?
Alice: 还没买面包呢
Alice: Haven't bought bread yet.
Katrina:  买个面包个番茄酱
Katrina: Let's buy some bread and ketchup.
Katrina:  OK走吧
Katrina: OK, let's go.
Lucia: 这里没有
Lucia: There's none here.
Lucia: 那天那个帝王蟹耶
Lucia: That day, there was a king crab.
Jake: 哈哈哈建立不了关联
Jake: Hahaha, can't establish a connection.
Jake: 关联建立失败
Jake: Connection failed.
Katrina:  哎这是吃饭点
Katrina: Hey, it's mealtime.
Lucia: 试一下建立别的关联
Lucia: Try establishing another connection.
Lucia: 那天还看到什么了
Lucia: What else did we see that day?
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 看馄饨
Jake: Look at the wontons.
Alice: 看我们有
Alice: Look, we have it.
Jake: 咋的
Jake: What's up?
Shure:  其实我们还可以弄点什么花蛤啥的
Shure: Actually, we could also get some clams or something.
其他人：牛奶了特价了
Others: Milk is on sale.
其他人：尝尝了哦
Others: Give it a try.
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure:  刚刚那会好像你们你们先往那边走
Shure: Just now, it seemed like you guys went that way first.
Jake: 可以喝三泡
Jake: You can drink three cups.
Jake: 谢谢你
Jake: Thank you.
Jake: 这哪家呀
Jake: Which shop is this?
其他人：哦原价卖39的现在卖22块9特价的
Others: Oh, it used to be 39, now it's on sale for 22.9.
Lucia: 小瓶那像这种
Lucia: The small bottles, like these.
Lucia: 然后可以分装
Lucia: And you can divide it.
Jake: 最小的
Jake: The smallest one.
Katrina: 简爱
Katrina: Simple Love.
Jake: 嗯呃简爱是哪个
Jake: Hmm, which one is Simple Love?
Katrina:  孩子买的小小装的
Katrina: The small pack that kids buy.
Jake: 他那个长的是这个
Jake: Is it this long one?
Jake: 玩是什么牌子呀
Jake: What's the brand?
Katrina:  下面这个吗
Katrina: Is it this one below?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 叫叫啥
Jake: What's it called?
Jake: 有牌子吗
Jake: Does it have a brand?
Jake: 我靠认不得
Jake: I can't recognize it.
Jake: 又在工作
Jake: Working again.
Jake: 天天工作
Jake: Working every day.